[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt's auf einem kanal eine
richtig schöne und vor allem sommerliche
torte das ist eine wickelt orte mit
bomben und erdbeeren mein brombeeren und
zitronen erdbeeren ich wollte erst
wahrnehmen aber auch kontrovers rohner
das passt und im innern habe ich nur am
brett technik und ob sie funktioniert
hat erfahren wir erst am ende des videos
mit die torte angeschnitten wird
unten haben wir dann richtig leckeren
fußball boden ja so positiv aus ich
zeige euch jetzt zuerst einmal wie man
den mittelteil zubereitet der muss
nämlich schön abkühlung für den
mittelteil verwendet e3 eine prise salz
150 gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt
jeweils 100 milliliter sonnenblumenöl
und buttermilch 150 gramm mehl einem
halb teelöffel backpulver und dem abrieb
von einer zitrone gebe ich zuerst einmal
die eier in eine rührschüssel die werden
nämlich gemeinsam mit zucker und dem
salz richtig cremig gerührt
es dauert also etwa fünf bis sechs
minuten da kommt direkt noch dass man in
der extrakt mit dazu
[Musik]
jetzt ist die eimasse richtig schön
cremig richtig schön dick schaumig
gerührt
jetzt kommen die zwei flüssigkeiten rein
also guter mensch um zum blumen statt
butter milch könnt ihr zum beispiel auch
eine limonade mineralwasser dann kurz
einrühren
die zutaten sie jetzt kurz dazu und den
abrieb von einer zitrone
[Musik]
ganz vorsichtig unterheben
jetzt völlig sind tag in meinem back
rahmen ein den habe ich bereits
eingestellt auf die größte stufe und die
tolle farbe vom teig die kommt übrigens
durch die eier zustande durch die bio
eier
und so wird der teig jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa zehn minuten
gebacken
[Musik]
der teig ist jetzt gebacken und kühlt
bereits ab und ich kann jetzt in der
zwischenzeit den genuss verboten machen
dafür verwende ich ein gramm
löffelbiskuits oder bis beziehungen 50
gramm cornflakes 125 gramm butter und 20
gramm schoko flex dann nämlich jetzt
schon flakes aber ihr könnt zum beispiel
auch schokostreusel verwenden es gebe
jetzt zuerst einmal die butter in einem
topf und lass dir schmelzen wuchs der
topf war schon an die nicht so schlimm
habe ich nur vergessen hat dass ich
abgelenkt und in der zwischenzeit kann
schon wirklich sitzungen zerteilung die
kommende keks bröselte mit dem herd habe
ich jetzt ausgemacht die restlichen
kekse noch
[Musik]
und die kontext riether kleine richtet
nur ganz oben
[Musik]
jetzt alles schön verrühren
wir kommen jetzt noch die schoko flex
mit rein
jetzt habe ich hier meinen tanten retter
da gebe ich eine back folie drauf und
einem pack bringt ihn habe ich bereits
auf 22 cm eingestellt und da kommt jetzt
die größte masse rein und wird schon
fest gedrückt und entweder nach der das
jetzt mit der hand oder in dem glas oder
und das ist mir neulich eingefahren
ach ich echt super perfekt dafür einfach
eine burger presse so hat die firma kann
man nämlich schön drücken hat genug
gewicht drauf und vor allem wird alles
schön flach gepresst und dann wandert
der keks boden dieser brösel boden
einfach kurz ins gefrierfach oder im
kühlschrank dieser schön fest ist
für die zitronen füllung verwende ich
zwei zitronen und davon 50 milliliter
saft und etwas von der zitronenschale 50
milliliter wasser 50 5 rama gaga für die
bombe erfüllung verwende ich 200 gramm
pomberg tiefgefrorene oder frische 50
gramm zucker 5 gramm agar agar und 50
milliliter wasser
jetzt stelle ich jetzt hier
zitronencreme herr das ist ähnlich wie
ein level könnt aber ohne ei und ohne
stärke das brauchen wir jetzt nämlich
nicht weil gaga benutze jetzt reichlich
einfach die zitronenschale ab und
deswegen ist es auch wichtig dass die
unbehandelt sind und nicht verspritzt
sind da kommt jetzt das wasser dazu und
jetzt kann ich den zitronensaft
auspressen und wie gesagt brauche ich da
auch als 50 milliliter
[Musik]
dann mit in den topf gemeinsam mit dem
zucker und aka aka und dann alles kurz
verrühren
und in dem zweiten topf da kommen jetzt
die bom bernrain hkk und das wasser kann
ich jetzt auch kurz berühren und jetzt
werden beide cremes aufgekocht oder
müssen sie mindestens zwei minuten lang
kochen damit dass engagierten kann und
später die creme bindet
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier beide frucht
füllungen umgefüllt damit sie einfach
ein bisschen schneller abkühlen und
einen teelöffel jeweils auf dem teller
gegeben und den kühlschrank gestellt da
mache ich immer die probe und wenn die
dann fest wird weiß ich okay alles hat
geklappt
jetzt kommen wir zur creme für die creme
verwende ich 500 gramm magerquark 250
gramm joghurt mit zehn prozent
fettanteil 300 milliliter sahne 100
gramm puderzucker 11 teelöffel seiner
tat und etwas markt und beim joghurt 80
wegen immer darauf dass es ein
zehnprozentiger ist so habe ich einfach
eine schöne cremige masse nämlich zuerst
den quark da kommt in die rührschüssel
gesundheit hier den joghurt dazu ich
finde da mache ich das doch schön frisch
gekelterten braucht bekommt jetzt die
sahne mit reinen als ich schlage jetzt
einfach alles in einer schüssel v oder
zucker sondern partner kommt gleich mit
rein wenn es schon ein bisschen verrührt
ist und natürlich ein bisschen weil der
extrakt und jetzt zu krähen verrührt und
steif schlagen
jetzt habe ich die creme und kann jetzt
nämlich einen teil mit der prom beckham
berühren und einen teil mit der zitrone
und beim ak und auch beim arbeiten mit
gelatine es immer wichtig zuerst zwei
bis drei esslöffel der kalten creme in
die warme themen einrühren und dann das
ganze hier rein damit einfach keine
klümpchen geht
[Musik]
es war ziemlich flüssig aus aber die
probe zeigt dass die creme wirklich
schön fest wird so wie hier
und auch hier besser proben werden mal
den finger gar nicht so fest wird
[Musik]
kann ich hier den teig in 6 cm breite
streifen schneiden und dann nehme ich
immer gern ein lineal dafür dann geht's
einfach und vor allem wie gleichmäßig
[Musik]
und jetzt möchte ich ja die torte füllen
und zwar um bdh den inneren weiß und
nach außen hin dunkel dh die helle
grämen kommt jetzt erst mal auf den
ersten und zweiten streifen und hier
oben kommt die dunkle creme und dafür
binden sie recht
[Musik]
glatte stelle ich jetzt ganz ganz kurz
im kühlschrank bis ich merke dass die
creme so leicht fester wird damit ich es
schön rollen kann
das dauert etwa zwei bis drei minuten
und in der zeit kann ich den oberboden
schon mal mit marmelade meiner wahl
besprechen
[Musik]
nämlich den ersten streifen das ist der
helle und der wird jetzt wie eine
schnecke aufgerollt deswegen ist auch
gut wenn die creme bisschen fester ist
dann hat man mehr stabilität und jetzt
die schnecke nehmen und direkt hier
platzieren datei gestalten so wunderbar
profis um jetzt die nächsten aus nahrung
sieht man sowieso nach zauberei aus aber
am ende sieht schön aus
[Musik]
jetzt den tortenring wir darum herum
setzen und schön fest ziehen und dadurch
bekommen die torte benötigte stabilität
die decke ich jetzt ab und stellt sie
für mindestens sechs stunden kühl oder
auch gerne über nacht
jetzt ist die torte gut durch gekühlt
und ich kann den bug ring entfernen
einmal am besten mit einem backform
messer
[Musik]
jetzt schneide ich hier oben die torte
schön gerade manchmal kann es passieren
dass er nicht ganz eben ist aber das ist
nicht schlimm
und ich hatte gestern noch ein bisschen
creme übrig und die nehme ich jetzt
einfach so zum bestreichen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die torte fertig gestrichen
jetzt nämlich mandelblättchen der mich
bereits gerüstet pfanne ohne fett und
abkühlen lassen und die kommen jetzt an
den rand der torte und ein paar bomben
auf die oberfläche
[Musik]
jetzt können wir die torte anschneiden
die ich es genau durchs bild geflogen
wir bringen die orie und beweise die
unbedingt noch dabei sein okay morath
ich bin gespannt
das mit der technik das habe ich mir
neulich auf der baustelle überlegt und
dann habe ich doch gleich
ich hoffe es hat geklappt
[Musik]
besser immer sauber machen
großes stück für einen großen mann hast
du nicht hast du mich gerade geht
nein ich hab dich gerade da kommt mir
das nur so ein bisschen komisch woher
ein co2 soll
[Musik]
okay nicht ganz ok aber außen dunkle
irgendwie ist nicht okay der farbverlauf
denen kann man natürlich schöner machen
jetzt sehen wir hier der teig ist
richtig schön geld ja wegen in bio eiern
und bio eier
ja das ist noch die eier die macher von
dial ihn haben wow entschuldigung was
ist wenn boden was sagen chapeau
streusel also löffel bist noch ein
cornflakes und butter und ihnen ist die
zitronencreme und außen die bombe creme
ja und der es weniger süßlich der ist
eher säuerlich weißt du ja sommerlich
und wenn man möchte kann man die torte
jetzt gerade im sommer wenn zu heiß ist
einfach nur für eine stunde oder zwei
ins gefrierfach stellen dann hat man
eine geeiste torte spiel tron rangemacht
ja vielleicht mag ihr drohen nun
außerdem so witzig ausländer zu drohen
ist also super genial wirklich fall
schon mal gesehen
gleichzeitig habe ich den grund mit
reiner calmund
ja vielen dank dass sie dabei war wir
sehen uns wieder nach den sommerferien
gerne könnt ihr weiterhin die videos
kommentieren ich gucke bestimmt ab und
so ein kommentar genau und meint meine
videos noch toll ja und deine wie das
genau um videos vom rat gibt es ja dann
im august jeder bei uns wird es reicht
er dann gab
wir wollen euch endlich über strom
abgenommen also ich fühle das sommerloch
sozusagen
5 das sommerloch okay okay also schönen
sommer wünsche ich euch macht schön viel
urlaub und badet und werde frauen zu
machen wir das auch irgendwie schon
komisch was so dass jetzt im sommerloch
[Musik]